this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular celebrities pop in to have a
drink
sometimes they share stories and even
secrets because as we all know what the
bartender ears is confidential isn't it
so I'm sitting there tending bar when in
walks someone I haven't seen in a long
time
sonic now sonic usually has a lot of
energy in and this time was no exception
but then it seemed a little reserved
this time and we sat down a order to
cramp a juice also he don't usually get
krump ages he says I know
well I've I've been through quite a lot
he seemed very twitchy to say the lazy
was constantly fidgeting with his hands
and looking left and right all the time
and I'll send his dress what's wrong
lace is very very fast manner he says
well I'm clean I'll don't do this often
amor also what stuff he says well you
know I was a addictive personality and I
I talk fast I just uh needs beats peaked
it's all about the speed and after a
while I just I got a ticket also
addicted to one day he said the rings
manner got addicted to the Rings and
I'll said the golden Power rings I said
yes I was addicted and I just got out of
rehab and I said oh wait a bit you went
to rehab for golden rings he says know
what to rehab for crystal meth but it
started off with the golden rings you
know after a while just made you go
faster faster faster that it just wasn't
enough it's all about the speed man he
says talk faster and faster just getting
more and more twitchy says I just I
could go fast enough had to go faster
faster beyond speed of life beyond the
speed of sound beyond the speed of speed
I don't know that meant but barely he
knew but it got to a point he said well
it's just dying to rule his life you
know he go to pawn shop so of all his
material possessions just in full rings
just awful rings of so sad and it got to
a point where I felt like the pawn shop
was ripping him over when they weren't
give him the best deal so he does that
spin wake up turns into a saw Howard
barely does that and he destroys all the
material and measure all the possessions
everything all the porn stuff just
totally destroyed well that lands in
there bit of trouble unfortunately he
sent to jail but luckily he says his
good friend tails bailed a mouse all
okay but um but tails had a different
agenda see tails actually a bit of a bit
of a push up you know to me he says I
have something even better than golden
rings it's these things called meth
rings they even know you can make rings
out of meth but there you go shows you
all know and Tails says to him you don't
even have to steal first ones free then
you have to pay him then you have to
steal but yeah so he gets really
addicted to the meth rings and
unfortunately we get really addicted to
these car things they're horrible
horrible side of things what do you
think is blue it's a side effect I'm a
blue hedgehog Steve oh but that wasn't
the only side effect II was physically
pushed to the limit I mean before I may
he was built like Arnold I mean he had
muscles boss if you wouldn't believe it
but now I mean his legs and arms then
like twinks and it kept telling me it's
all about the speed all about the speed
I couldn't get enough you're so into it
that he could even see really what tails
was doing you know they use a dealer I
mean that that was one thing but what he
found out he is working for Robotnik
thousand that strong he just would
believe that tails at Robotnik would be
working together but their Lyra Baltic
uh limited on the stuff early on too as
the power of those rings I mean it is a
drug it is an addiction and
unfortunately it was just getting more
and more out of control you know he was
picking fights with all the big ones
Speedy Gonzales the Roadrunner flash he
would always challenge them the races of
course he would always win does excite
dope on the Rings it's like steroids in
room four
with meth so go around picking fights
with everybody racing them all they ran
out of ideas he challenged slowpoke
Rodriguez but that was a mismatch I can
tell you that wasn't enough he says it
was all about the speed more speed he
says after a while he started out
running race cars trains all because of
the ring devil always chasing the golden
dragon I think the lowest point was when
they found him at Six Flags on the
Batman ride just going around on the
loops over and over and over and over it
would have done something earlier but
people just assumed his won the costume
mascots they finally found him face down
to the bathroom urinal with a traffic
cone on his head and cotton candy in his
bomb that was a sorry sight for the kids
seeing an American icon with his face
down piss people thought they drowned a
smurf it was a sad sight to say the
least
finally the police decided this was a
problem at the need to be dealt with so
they locked him in a rubber room where
he was bouncing off the walls literally
he can do that
his supersonic speed is literally
bouncing off the walls it was quite an
amazing sight from what I understand but
he said those days were just gonna house
crime vengeance at the pixel palace and
that will being I thought I might say
well why did you need the speed anyway
was it really necessary I mean they are
so much in your life and yeah so much
going for you why would you need rogues
the natural high of life there should be
enough
speed is not the answer drugs are never
the answer
it's life like that's the answer not
speed it's never speed
he then pissed all over the bar ran
circles around the tables he also did
tap dance on the chandelier singing go
Speed Racer go see he was on speed at
the time I didn't know that so I get a
little drill didn't call pixel Palace
security and he strips down totally
naked and starts dancing across the bar
of course stripping naked for him is
just take out the gloves and shoes but
for animal morphic life-form that's
still very shocking so security comes in
the trials to him to calm down whether
you want a penny of it so he rushed to
the roof howled at the moon in sister he
could fly jumped off the building and
plummeted to the sidewalk see he
couldn't fly turns out the only thing
that can stall momentum like that is the
ground five inches of thick cement to be
exact two inches after they peeled him
off the sidewalk and he looks at me as
they dragged over to the police car they
says if the first you don't succeed a
chicken a charm stun did I mention he
was on drugs it's so sad to see things
like that's just so sad great American
Idol so come to rings meth rings I don't
know when people go I just wake up
you see a lot of strange things as a
bartender seal all strange things at the
pixel Palace so I see a lot of strange
things as a bartender at the pixel
Palace
that's no line